MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting development community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm glad
somebody has asked this
question
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions?
DAN HOLEVOET: All right.
Hi, everybody.
Welcome to another session
of Google App
Engine Office Hours.
Today I'm going to be walking
you through some of the
advancements in Google Cloud
Endpoints, which many of you
may know we announced at
Google I/O in June.
So for any of you that aren't
familiar with endpoints, we'll
be giving you a little bit of
a summary and a refresher on
what that new technology is.
And then we're also going to
go and show you some of the
things that we didn't actually
talk about at I/O as well.
So I prepared some slides
for you, so we'll
switch over to those.
And we'll get started.
So the topic today is a Google
Cloud Endpoints points using
Java as the back end
implementation, JavaScript for
actually consuming the
endpoints, and some
information on how to use both
of those and OAuth 2 as well.
So if you're not familiar with
Google Cloud Endpoints , as I
said, this is a technology we
announced at Google I/O. It's
a feature of App Engine that
allows you to create a
scalable API, hosted on App
Engine, that also uses many of
the pieces of Google's
API infrastructure.
So when you're building APIs
on Google Cloud Endpoints,
you're building them on the same
technologies that we use
to build Google APIs.
So things like the Google
Calendar API, Google Plus
APIs, many of the APIs that
you're probably already
familiar with and
already using.
And what's great about--
[NO AUDIO]
DAN HOLEVOET: --like, well, if
I get 10 requested a second,
can I make that 100
very easily?
Yes, you can.
So if you saw any of the content
that we shared at I/O,
whether it was the session that
I was participating in or
the codelabs or some of the
other sessions, one of the
things that we showed off
was a simple tic-tac-toe
application that would allow you
to power a simple Web game
or an Android game or an i/OS
game that let you play
tic-tac-toe.
And so this is a very simple
diagram showing you what the
very basic architecture
is for that game.
So we have a datastore which
is keeping track of the
previous games that
you've played.
We have that datastore being
modified by Google App Engine.
We have Google Cloud Endpoints
as a layer exposing two simple
API is from Google App Engine to
a Web interface, an Android
interface, and an
iOS interface.
And so you can see here,
this is what the
game might look like.
If I click on one of these
squares-- whoops.
I accidentally advanced
my slides here.
Let me see if I can go back.
Well, you can still see it.
So I click on one of
the squares, the
computer fills in a move.
It's not terribly bright, so it
let me win there, but you
can see that this has
demonstrated that
I won at the bottom.
And if we scroll down, we can
also see-- let's see if I can
get this back.
Let's refresh.
No.
Not working.
Well, you can still see--
if I can manage to get
this to scroll over.
There we go.
You can see that I've won this
particular game and then also
tied in a previous
game as well.
So we'll talk a little bit about
some of the details on
how this type of system
was implemented.
So as I mentioned, this is one
of the examples that we used
at I/O. And this is basically
the model that we're storing
in the datastore that represents
the previously
played games.
So whenever we finished a game
of tic-tac-toe, we're going to
save an instance of the score
class inside of our datastore.
And so if you're familiar with
Java development on App
Engine, one of the
implementations that we
support for interacting with
a datastore is called JDO.
And this is a really simple
JDO class that
represents a score.
So there's actually nothing
custom in this class that's
unique to using Google
Cloud Endpoints.
This is the same type of code
that you would write yourself
if you were implementing any
other type of application in
Java on App Engine.
So we have a couple
properties here.
We have a unique identifier
that represents the score.
We have the player who
played the game.
We have the outcome of
the game, and we
have when it was played.
This is also some of the code
that we showed you at I/O.
This is a really simple endpoint
class that implements
a tic-tac-toe API.
We've cut out some of the
methods that do things like
get previous scores and list all
the scores to just focus
on one of the examples.
So in this particular case,
we're inserting a new score
from a game that we
just finished
playing into the datastore.
And so you can see here we have
some properties, like the
name of the API, what version
the API is, tic-tac-toe and
Version 1.0, respectively.
We're giving the API
method a name.
So this is inserting one of the
scores into the datastore.
And then we have some really
simple code to take the score
that we sent to the App
Engine back end and
persist it for us.
So now we're going to talk about
some of the new things
that we're going to see today
and how we can combine this
with OAuth 2 in JavaScript to
actually implement the front
end for this application.
So the first thing that we're
going to do is we're going to
add another property to the API
annotation, and that's for
the client ID.
So what this is basically doing
is it's saying for any
request that's made to this API,
I would like to make sure
that it is coming from an
application represented by
whatever client ID
I've specified.
So if you're not familiar with
OAuth 2, a client ID is
basically a way of identifying
an application.
And if you've used any of
Google's other APIs, you may
have used the API's console,
which is where you would get a
client ID for your
own application.
So in the same way that you
represent your application to
Google, you are representing
your application when you call
Google Cloud Endpoints.
So here you can see an example
of client ID ABC123.apps.goog
leusercontent.com.
You can put multiple values in
there if you'd like, multiple
client IDs or applications to
be accessing your APIs.
But if it doesn't show up in
that list, the request will
obviously not succeed.
So the next thing that we're
going to do is we're going to
say, OK, well, we've said what
applications we want these
requests to come from, but once
we've done that how do we
figure out what user
it is that's
actually making a request?
And doing this inside of an
endpoint class is actually
really simple.
The only thing that we have to
really do is add this code
here that I'm highlighting.
We're adding the user object
as a parameter in our
invocation to the
insert method.
So this is the exact same user
service that you might have
used inside of other App
Engine applications.
So if you're using a user object
somewhere else inside
of your code, and you use it
inside of Google Cloud
Endpoints, this is actually
exactly the same.
So you can see here we're then
setting the score, the player
of this particular game, to the
user that is sending this
request So that we can persist
it inside of the datastore.
And then if you were to use that
user object later, if you
want to query all of the scores
from a particular user,
it's exactly the same
type of object.
If you're doing other types
of interactions with the
datastore outside of Cloud
Endpoints, again, it's exactly
the same user service that
you're already used to using.
And then, of course,
we're persisting
it as we were before.
And then for cases where we
actually do not have a valid
request from a user, we're
throwing an OAuth request
exception, which will be
properly propagated back to
any of the clients that are
calling these APIs.
So if you combine the two of
those, this is what the final
code would look like for
our back end service.
You can call it V2 of the
tic-tac-toe API that now
properly supports OAuth
via the user service.
So let's move on to how you
would implement the front end
code for this in JavaScript.
So in the demos that we showed
at I/O we had a really simple
example using the
Google-provided JavaScript
client library.
And basically when that loads
we call initialization
functions that load up all
of the APIs that we're
interested in using.
So in that particular example,
we're only interested in
loading the tic-tac-toe API.
And this is what the code for
that looked like when we
showed it off at I/O.
Now that we're interested in
using OAuth 2, we're going to
add another API into
that code.
And once that API has loaded,
we're going to attempt to sign
in the user.
So you can see here
the API that we're
loading is an OAuth 2.
This is of course V2 of OAuth.
And then we're calling a sign-in
method, which I can
show you now as well.
So what this does is it calls
a built-in function of the
JavaScript client library
called authorize.
It takes the client ID
for your application.
Again, this is the same client
ID that you passed into your
back end code, one or more API
scopes that you're interested
in using, such as the
userinfo.email scope, and mode.
And we'll talk about that
more in just a second.
And then a response type, which
type of tokens you're
interested in getting back.
So the mode here is there's
two configurations
that you can use.
The first mode is
immediate mode.
And what that will attempt to do
is basically authorize the
user without initiating
a prompt.
So basically that pop-up window
that you might be used
to seeing won't appear.
But this will only work if the
user has already previously
granted access to your
application.
And you might say, well, let's
say the user hasn't granted
authorization in the past.
Well, we'll get to that
in just a second.
So here we'll assume that the
user has already logged into
the application before.
So when your page gets loaded,
they'll automatically be
logged back in again, and then
your application can continue.
So this is basically what the
callback function would look
like once the user
has authorized.
We're going to basically make
a request here to get
information about the
user, such as the
user's email address.
Properly save the token,
and then we
can call our endpoints.
And then finally, to handle the
case where the user has
never authorized the application
before, we'll add
a little bit of code to our
UI, like a sign-in button.
And when that button is clicked,
it will call a method
such as Auth here, which we'll
call that authorized method
again without using
immediate mode.
And then we'll pass that through
to the same callback
method that we used
previously.
So the best part about this is
that it's relatively simple to
add OAuth 2 to your
implementations of your
client, so in the JavaScript
client like we showed here.
But the actual code
to call the APIs
hasn't changed at all.
So this is exactly the same code
that we used in the demos
at I/O to insert a new score
into the datastore.
And all of the pieces around
OAuth 2 have basically just
been transparently added
in the background of
all of these requests.
So there's nothing special that
we need to do once we're
actually writing our code to
make sure that OAuth 2
continues to work.
All that's handled just a single
time right up front.
So hopefully you found this
demo interesting.
If you haven't already signed
up for the Trusted Tester
Program for Google Cloud
Endpoints, there's a
link to that here.
We'll provide a link to these
slides in the information
about this hangout.
We also have a link to the
codelab, which I also showed
at I/O, so you can follow
through the complete
development of a
Java back end.
And then I have a link to the
little IFrame demo that I
showed earlier in the slides
if you'd like to play
tic-tac-toe yourself.
And then you can also inspect
the entire source code of the
front end of the application,
so all of the JavaScript
that's powering that demo.
And with that, I think we're
done with slides.
And I think we have some
questions from the moderator
that we can go through?
AMY: Can you hear me, Dan?
DAN HOLEVOET: Yes.
I can hear you.
AMY: Great.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Amy, another App Engine
devrel, Developer Regulations.
So I'm going to be the
moderator, question reader.
OK.
And so I'm going to start one
that I think is most related
to this presentation.
Some APIs, email settings,
requires a super user to
authenticate.
When running the Web
application, only the end user
is authorizing access.
How best to intermix that
authorization with normal end
user authorization?
DAN HOLEVOET: So I think that
there's really a couple pieces
to the answer for
this question.
So one of those is that on App
Engine we have the concept of
service accounts, or actually
Google APIs have the concept
of service accounts, which
basically allow you to call an
API that's not necessarily
representing a
request from a user.
So a lot of those administrative
type of APIs,
the request that they're
making to update some
organization-specific
information, a lot of the time
those are coming from services
rather than active users.
But then there's also the
concept of two-legged OAuth,
which I think is maybe more
interesting in this case.
So something like the email
settings API, only an
administrator can access that
particular API, but they might
want to do it on behalf
of another user.
So let's say the domain
administrator for an
organization wants to update
the email signatures of all
the people at their company.
They might call the email
settings API on behalf of a
specific user in order to update
those email settings.
So without a little bit more
detail on what the specific
API is that we're trying to
call, I don't think we can
give a complete answer.
But those are two of the
technologies that might be
useful in that case.
AMY: OK.
The next question is a
little more general.
Is there a way to backup and
restore data within any Google
infrastructure?
Not like Google Drive, but
much larger, mostly for
archiving purposes?
If not, is such a service
in the plan or
are there other providers?
So this is not directly related
to Cloud Endpoints.
I can take a stab at part
of it and then you
can elaborate, Dan.
DAN HOLEVOET: Sure.
AMY: But there's a free
your data initiative.
I can't remember exactly what
that's called, but it's
actually a big effort to let you
get all of the data that
you own out of all the various
Google services.
Do you remember what that
is called exactly, Dan?
DAN HOLEVOET: Is it called--
it might be called Take Out.
AMY: It might be, yeah.
Yeah, so there are some things
supported like that.
Perhaps a little more
pertinently to App Engine and
other cloud services, something
else that you might
investigate is Google Cloud
Storage, which is very good
for easily archiving and
accessing lots of data.
And it plays well with BigQuery
and Google Compute
Engine when that's more
widely available.
And it's really fast
and scalable.
So you might check into that.
Anything to add?
DAN HOLEVOET: No, I think that
pretty much covers it.
I would wonder why they wouldn't
consider Drive for
archival storage as well.
I mean, unless we're talking
really huge amounts of data in
which maybe the price is not
quite suitable for that.
But I think it would
work there, too.
AMY: Yeah, that's another
[INAUDIBLE].
OK.
Let's see.
Here's one that I'm not sure I
know how to interpret without
some clarification.
It says, I know how to loop
through all the documents and
nest collections.
But how would you access all
the unresolved comments for
each document?
DAN HOLEVOET: Yeah, I'm--
AMY: I think we might need a
little more context on that
one, sorry.
Yeah.
And I would encourage
people to post
questions on Stack Overflow.
So since we can't talk to the
person directly right now who
posted that question, do ask it
on Stack Overflow and add a
little more detail.
DAN HOLEVOET: Yeah,
definitely.
All right.
Are those the only moderator
questions?
AMY: Let's see.
Yeah.
Those are the only ones.
DAN HOLEVOET: Great.
Do you have anything to add
about Cloud Endpoints?
AMY: I don't.
That was an excellent
presentation, Dan.
DAN HOLEVOET: Thank you.
AMY: And I would encourage
everyone to go
play with the codelab.
We'll post the links to the
slides, and from there you'll
find the codelab link.
I've played around with it,
and it's kind of fun.
It's really great.
DAN HOLEVOET: Yeah, I should
note that the codelab doesn't
actually require that you're
white listed until you
actually deploy to App Engine.
So if you just want to try it
out and you say, well, I'm not
sure if I want to apply, or
you're not sure if you'll get
in immediately, you can try
out many of the steps.
I think up through step four
of the codelab, which is
actually fairly significant,
even without deploying
anything to App Engine.
AMY: And I'd also add, just
because we get this question
periodically, people also wonder
if Cloud Endpoints are
supported in Python.
And yes, they are, even
though the codelab
doesn't touch on that.
DAN HOLEVOET: Right, exactly.
And I will hope to share some
more information on the Python
development environment for
Endpoints, perhaps in a future
hangout
AMY: Yeah, a future
mini tech talklet.
So yes, for those of you who
aren't tuning into on these
necessarily every week, where
we're starting to have a goal
of presenting a lot of these
little mini tech talks pretty
much every week and then just
also take regular App Engine
Office Hour-type
questions, too.
So we hope to give you these
little chunks of information
every week.
Hopefully something that's
relatively new maybe that you
haven't played around with
it yet or don't have much
information on yet.
So stay tuned.
DAN HOLEVOET: All
right, great.
Well, if that's all the
questions, then thanks
everyone for tuning in.
And we'll see you
all next time.